here we are again okay these are the quo
your back alright let me let me find one
for you okay I'm a rusted D amorosa do
you anticipate more top officials in the
White House defecting and speaking out
against him well nikki Haley she I guess
she beat the holiday rush and got out
[Laughter]
who's next after the midterms when the
Democrats take back control of the house
and possibly the Senate I think you'll
see a great defection there'll be a mass
exodus and everybody will be trying to
fight to write another book or tell the
story so I worry about who's after
though I mean you know that we thought
the first crew was bad but I'm like what
no no no not you I mean I mean like Rex
Tillerson you know I said they're not
now I'm like could we get Rex Tillerson
back in there it doesn't Chevron have
someone who could step into that poster
okay Ryan is the US Army justified in
its decision to discharge over 500
immigrant recruits in the last year well
if you're talking about I think it's the
nav and I program I think that it's just
it's frankly one of these things that's
less a policy decision than some kind of
administrative [ __ ] up in which there
just are a lot of different pieces to it
but I have to know the specifics of the
case involved I do think that when there
are folks who don't pass a background
check and what-have-you but I honestly
don't know specifically we're very
careful on this show careful Eddie is
free speech on campus being stifled with
students protesting controversial
speakers I mean what about that part of
political correctness that you can't
speak on campus the home of free speech
anymore
I think that's overstated really yeah
you can imagine after Milo spoke today
you say he probably went someplace else
and spoke without any any any incident
you think about charles Murray at
Middlebury he probably wound up which he
did it in why you the next day without
any incident so if that pick where you
can speak no no values what I'm saying
there are thousands of lectures on
college campuses across
the ideological spectrum that happen
everyday without these incidents what
you usually write a lot about it a lot I
know that's because that's because it's
it's sensational just like you in your
opening monologue you talk about the
weatherman that guy remember that guy in
the weather report where the wind was
blowing and the people were walking
behind him and casually sometimes we
report about what's happening on
campuses in a sensationalized matter
okay
all right Steve one in how should
Democrats address how badly they are
polling with Latinos yeah you know that
is the if there's one worried area for
Democrats in terms of November that's it
right there
and I think one of the issues there is
it's almost more fundamental when we
think of the Latino vote often in the
media and in politics we treat it as
okay immigration and we think that is
the major issue that's gonna drive it
and we expect that therefore Democrats
are gonna get the lion's share the
Latino vote and yet there's a recent
poll that said ask Latino voters what is
your top issue it was not immigration it
was the economy yeah one third of
Latinos identified as conservatives 1/4
identified as Republicans I think Ryan
had the poll there from a couple weeks
ago that had Trump's approval in in one
hitting 41% with Latino voters I've seen
it between 35 and 41 percent and also
you have a historically a low
participation level lower relative to
every other group out there among Latino
voters especially in midterm elections
so if you're a Democrat and you're
looking at California Texas Florida a
couple other districts around the
country where potentially Latino vote is
gonna make or break you I think that's
your biggest concern right now you got
two suburban energy you got the money I
think that's a big factor for them okay
Rebecca why do so many liberals peg
Milani as a victim rather than as a
willing participant in a crooked family
god I don't know
you don't know I've even you know
bananas there is such there's such an
impulse to I mean maybe it's about the
you know ever renewing hope for white
women but maybe it's about that same
impulse to think to want to make a
secret hero out of somebody next to him
when it is so clear that Melania Ivanka
these women are propping him up deriving
power participating participating in the
oppression and the destruction of the
democracy and I don't know it drives me
crazy when I say that I loathe as much
as the hope that the the idea that
Melania is some kind of secret agent in
there resisting no she's she's horrific
as Republicans are still chanting lock
her up at Trump rallies is it necessary
for Democrats to publicly distant selves
from Hillary Clinton I guess this is
Clinton in order to move on from 2016
it's amazing the way they they do still
Hillary is still like if she was as if
she was president yeah it's the idea
that we could run away from the open
calls to violent misogyny by distancing
ourselves from one lady you notice that
they they shout it hurt it doesn't it's
not about Hillary it's about lock any of
them up you said in your monologue it
was Dianne Feinstein this week yeah you
know it's lock her up stands up stands
in for a much bigger metaphor for what
they want to do Donald Trump's political
just to try to turn a strength into a
weakness so when you look at the
enormous enthusiasm you have on the left
you talk about angry mobs right you turn
it into something that looks scary and
threatening so that people will rally
around it and that's part of what makes
him so effective that's why he's able to
cut down all of his rivals in the
Republican primaries when he has a rival
a clearly-defined rival then he can be
very very effective at trying to turn
their strengths into weaknesses and
that's why when you have an actual
Democratic nominee that's the moment
when he might become a lot more
politically effective than Diaz when he
does not have a clearly defined rival
both that and he might just need a new
chant leader
I mean I've attended these rallies when
we were on the campaign and there's a
guy at the rally who leads these chants
and he just might want my back
absolutely he just might need a new
playlist instead of lock lock her up
lock her up they might need something
new to say like lock him up
the fact that we're talking about that
an American politician saying lock her
up yeah about anybody American
politician the most powerful yes in the
world it's it's so third-world and and
you know there's so many books called
basically it could happen here I'm still
surprised how many people you also see
populist politicians and pretty much all
of the market democracies around the
world who are gaining in prominence this
is not just a u.s. phenomenon it's a
global phenomenon and I don't think
we're seeing the last of it I think
we'll see more of it in the years to
come
all right thank you everybody thank you
panel
you